when President Trump signed the 1.4
trillion dollar budget into law last
night he also approved sweeping changes
to retirement savings rules this week
the Senate passed the setting every
community up for retirement enhancement
also known as the secure Act
it's the biggest set of changes to
retirement investment rules in more than
a decade so how will it affect your
savings is the question here with more
on this is Yahoo Finance reporter Sabeel
Marcellus good morning good morning
these all these this rule changes the
rule changes start January 1st 2020 just
give us a broad sense of some of the
changes people are going to see yeah so
there are three big takeaways of the
secure act this is important because
it's the first big change we're seeing
when it comes to America's retirement
system so number one it raises the age
for when you're required to take money
out of your retirement account from age
70 and a half to age 72 number two it
also allows you to continue to
contribute to your retirement account
past age 70 and a half and that's really
important because Americans are working
longer and living longer so if you're 70
years old or 71 years old and you're
already receiving a paycheck you may
still want to contribute to your
retirement account and let that grow and
be as big as possible for when you are
no longer able to work or willing to
work the other third change that I
really want to mention here has to do
with inherited retirement accounts so
that's when the owner of an account
passes away and their loved ones
actually are able to inherit it and
throughout their life before they were
able to tap into that account and they
were able to use that money but now with
this new legislation it caps it after
ten years you have to take that money
out now the reason why we're seeing this
in this legislation is because we have
to pay for these provisions and this is
how the government is doing now the
Congressional Budget Office estimates
that with this inherited retirement
account this new rule right they'll be
able to generate fifteen point seven
billion dollars over ten years so
uncocks that you're paying on that right
so Uncle Sam taking a bigger chunk yeah
of every time it savings there so 401ks
big big way a lot of us used to like
accrue our wealth right for retirement
what are the changes there there's some
big way there's some big ones yes so
with the four
one case so small businesses they're the
backbone of the US economy and they
employ a lot of people but offering 401
k's to their employees is really costly
it's cumbersome it's complicated so this
legislation allows them to band together
as a group a couple different small
businesses and offer these benefits and
get tax credits so that's great for
Americans the other change with 401 K is
that it now will encourage corporations
to offer their employees annuities as a
part of their 401ks annuities are great
because it's like when you're working
every two weeks you get your paycheck
you can set up annuities in your 401 K
so that after you're no longer working
you can still receive money you know and
a for example every two weeks you can
set it up however you want it so you can
kind of balance your budget after you're
no longer working why is all this
happening now yes so this is happening
now because when you look at Federal
Reserve data a quarter of Americans have
no retirement savings at all so we're
facing a crisis here when it comes to
Social Security there are reports that
it could be insolvent in 16 years so a
lot of people are counting on their
retirement accounts to be a safe cushion
of money for them when they can no
longer work so this legislation
encourages more people to save for
retirement it makes it easier to do so I
know go ahead go ahead
I was gonna say I know one of the things
you mentioned before was that raised and
the higher age now when you have to when
you have to start taking your benefits I
guess what is the benefit of that for
people that may be getting closer to
that yeah so the benefit is that if
you're working longer you want to
continue to save for retirement continue
to contribute to that account because
the stock market right now is on a tear
it's reaching record highs all three
major indices hit highs recently so you
want to benefit from that you don't
wanna take that money to soon if you
don't really need it so that's what this
legislation allows you to do we're
trying to break all this down for you
you're doing a great job doing it but
this does get into the weeds a little
bit so if you're out there and watching
and maybe we're spending a little time
with some of these rules that sort of
understand how it affects how it affects
your family so bill thank you very much
thank you holidays
you